>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK TO
OUR SPECIAL "FRUMP THIS ASIA"
EDITION OF "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE ARE STANDING ON THE NORTH
KOREAN BORDER.
OUR INTERVIEW WITH THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T SIMPLY FOCUS
ON FOREIGN POLICY OR DECAYS OF
THE AMERICAN CITIES.
YOU COULD FILL HOURS OF
PROGRAMMING ON THOSE TOPICS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
BEING INCREASELY OPEN OF THE
DECADES' LONG INVESTIGATION OF
U.F.O.s.
OFFICIALS ADMIT NOW THEY HAVE
SEEN MANY THINGS THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
WE DECIDED TO ASK THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT IT.
HERE IS HIS SEMI-CRYPTIC
ANSWER.
YOU GAVE A INTERVIEW THE OTHER
DAY WHERE YOU SAID YOU HAVE
BEEN BRIEFED ON UNIDENTIFIED
FLYING OBJECTS.
ARE THEY REAL?
>> President Trump: I DON'T
WANT TO GET INTO IT TOO MUCH.
PERSONALLY, I TEND TO DOUBT
IT.
I MEAN YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT
SWEAR BY IT, RIGHT?
PILOTS HAVE COME IN AND THEY
SAID -- AND THESE ARE PILOTS,
NOT PILOTS THAT ARE INTO THAT
PARTICULAR WORLD.
BUT WE HAVE HAD PEOPLE SAYING
THAT THEY HAVE SEEN THINGS.
I'M NOT A BELIEVER BUT YOU
KNOW, I GUESS ANYTHING IS
POSSIBLE.
>> Tucker: WE SPOKE TO A
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL RECENTLY
WHO SAID THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
HAD WRECKAGE FROM THE U.F.O.
IN AN FACILITY ON AIR FORCE
BASE.
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THAT?
>> President Trump: I HAVE
NOT HEARD THAT.
IN THE GOVERNMENT, I HAVE NOT
SEEN IT.
I HAVE SEEN IT ON YOUR SHOW.
BUT I DON'T ASSUME IT'S
CORRECT.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE AN OPEN MIND,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU DO,
MR. PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> President Trump: NOW DAYS
YOU CAN BELIEVE ANYTHING,
RIGHT?
>> Tucker: NICK POPE IS A
JOURNALIST AND HE ONCE
INVESTIGATED U.F.O. SIGHTINGS
FOR THE BRITISH MINISTRY OF
DEFENSE AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
NICK, I THOUGHT IT WAS AN
INTERESTING ANSWER.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE HAD BEEN
BRIEFED.
"I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO IT."
BUT HE IS SKEPTICAL THAT
U.F.O.s ARE REAL.
WHAT DOES THAT ADD UP TO,
WOULD YOU SAY?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I THINK
IT'S ABSOLUTELY REFRESHING TO
GET A STRAIGHT ANSWER FROM A
PRESIDENT.
A SITTING PRESIDENT ON THIS
WITHOUT DODGING THE QUESTION.
WITHOUT MAKING SOME HUMOROUS
REFERENCE TO A SCIENCE FICTION
MOVIE.
THAT WAS GOOD TO HEAR.
I UNDERSTAND THAT SKEPTICISM.
I THINK EVERYONE THAT STARTED
OFF LOOKING AT THIS WITHIN
GOVERNMENT STARTS SKEPTICAL.
BUT AS YOU SAY, THIS REFERENCE
TO THE BRIEFING THAT HE HAD IS
VERY INTERESTING.
WHEN HE SAYS HE DOESN'T WANT
TO GET INTO THIS, DOES THAT
REFLECT JUST THAT HE IS
PERSONALLY NOT THAT INTERESTED
OR MAYBE THAT HE RECEIVED SOME
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION THAT HE
IS NOT ABLE TO SHARE ABOUT ALL
THIS?
>> Tucker: WE SPOKE TO A
U.S., A CREDIBLE, NON-CRAZY
U.S. OFFICIAL WHO SAID
CATEGORICALLY FLAT OUT THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS WRECKAGE
FROM A U.F.O.
DIDN'T SAY IT WAS
EXTRATERRESTRIAL.
IT WAS AN UNIDENTIFIED FLYING
OBJECT.
AND THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS
MATERIAL FROM THAT AIRCRAFT.
WHATEVER IT IS.
THAT IS AN AMAZING CLAIM.
HOW WOULD THE PRESIDENT NOT
HAVE HEARD THAT?
ASSUMING IT'S TRUE.
>> WELL, I THINK -- YEAH, I
THINK THAT IS THE BIG THING.
ASSUMING IT'S TRUE.
I WOULD THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS PROBABLY ASKED
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
CHIEFS FIRSTLY, IS THERE A
THREAT HERE TO THE UNITED
STATES?
AND SECONDLY SETTING THAT
QUESTION ASIDE, WHAT ARE WE
DEALING WITH?
IS THIS OUR OWN TECH?
IS IT RUSSIA?
IS IT CHINA?
OR IS IT FROM SOMEWHERE
FURTHER AFIELD?
I MEAN, HE WILL HAVE ASKED FOR
ALL INFORMATION HELD ON THIS.
AND WILL BE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT TO DO.
HE HAS SAID HIMSELF SOMETHING
FEELS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
WITH ALL THIS.
WITH THE U.S. NAVY PILOTS AND
THE RADAR OPERATORS NOW COMING
FORWARD.
THERE IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT,
IMPORTANT AND BIG HAPPENING.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY SINCE YOU SPEAK TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE INVOLVED IN
THIS, NOT JUST IN THE
PROFESSIONAL U.F.O.
QUESTIONING WORLD, WHICH I
THINK MOST OF US HAVE A RIGHT
TO BE A LITTLE SKEPTICAL OF.
BUT ORDINARY PILOTS AND PEOPLE
GOING ABOUT THEIR IT BE IN
GOVERNMENT WHO HAVE
INTERSECTED WITH THE STORIES
OR SEEN THE ON THES
THEMSELVES, WHAT IS THE
MAJORITY VIEW ABOUT WHAT THESE
ARE?
RUSSIAN, CHINESE, AMERICAN OR
SOMETHING ELSE?
>> WELL, I'M NOT SURE THERE IS
A MAJORITY VIEW.
EVEN WITHIN GOVERNMENT.
I HAVE BEEN HERE MYSELF WITH
THE BRITISH MINISTRY OF
DEFENSE.
THERE WERE CONFLICTING
OPINIONS.
I MEAN, LOOK, IF THE PRESIDENT
WOULD LIKE MORE RESEARCH AND
MORE BRIEFING, I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO HELP WITH THAT.
YOU COULD PROBABLY ROUND UP A
COUPLE OF FORMER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS FROM WITHIN THE
U.S. ADMINISTRATION TO WHO
HAVE LOOKED AT THIS.
AND WE COULD CERTAINLY, I'M
SURE, YOU KNOW, GET PEOPLE
AFRAID WHO ARE NOT AFRAID TO
THINK THE UNTHINKABLE AND ASK
THE PEOPLE WHAT IF QUESTIONS.
BUT WHATEVER HAPPENS WITH
U.F.O.s, IT MAY HAPPEN ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WATCH.
WE MAY GET WITH THE CURRENT
RADIO TELESCOPES, CERTAINLY
WITH THE NEXT GENERATION
TELESCOPES WE MIGHT GET
ABSOLUTE CONFIRMATION THAT THE
OTHER CIVILIZATIONS ARE OUT
THERE.
THEREFORE, IT MIGHT HAPPEN ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WATCH.
HE WILL BE THE ONE WHO HAS TO
MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT.
WHAT AN HISTORIC ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT WOULD BE.
"MY FELLOW AMERICANS, PEOPLE
OF THE WORLD, WE ARE NOT
ALONE."
SO I'M GLAD TO HEAR HE IS
OPEN-MINDED AND THINKING ABOUT
THIS.
THERE HAS BEEN AN UP-SURGE IN
THE SIGHTINGS AND WHO KNOWS
WHAT THE FUTURE WILL BRING?
>> Tucker: SOMETHING
TERRIFYING ABOUT ALL THAT.